in regenerativen energien steckt eine
menge potenzial und sie können einen
riesigen beitrag dazu leisten den
klimawandel
zumindest noch zu verlangsamen doch
immer wieder ist auch von hohen kosten
der erneuerbaren energien die rede und
genau deswegen gibt es jetzt für euch
den großen kosten check wie stehen die
erneuerbaren energien im vergleich da
ihr habt euch das thema bei whatsapp
gewünscht und ich sage danke für diesen
vorschlag herzlich willkommen bei pixum
science fiction
vor einigen jahren bin ich auf einen
dinosaurier ingenieur getroffen er
beklagte sich ernsthaft über die
subventionierung von windkraftwerken und
lobte dagegen die kernenergie
die sei ja so billig naja ich erinnerte
ihn an ein paar milliardenschwere bau wo
ihnen in deutschland den schnellen
brüter in kalkar den kugelhaufen reaktor
in hamm oder das stillgelegte kernkraft
in mülheim kärlich das steht in einem
erdbebengebiet oh man aber ist die
kernkraft nicht an sich total billig war
braucht ja nur total wenig brennstoff um
jahre lang energie zu erzeugen naja aber
die gefahren aber kommen wir zu der
kostenbilanz fest steht der klimawandel
kann wohl nur noch aufgehalten oder
zumindest verlangsamt werden wenn wir
möglichst schnell auf erneuerbare
energien umschwenken
und die sind im gegensatz zur kernkraft
nämlich ungefährlich das ist und das zu
recht ein dauerbrennerthema hier bei
pixum science fiction denn die lage ist
wirklich ernst denn klar ist dass
energieformen wie wind und solarenergie
sehr viele vorteile haben sie sind
unbegrenzt weltweit ohne langen und
kostspieligen transport verfügbar und
ölkatastrophen die verstärkung des
treibhauseffektes und akw unfälle können
vermieden werden aber es gibt eben auch
schattenseiten
diese art der stromerzeugung ist stark
vom wetter abhängig nehmen wir nur als
beispiel die photovoltaik die
herausforderungen für das stromnetz
besteht darin die schwankungen
abzupuffern und auszugleichen
beispielsweise in dem der strom
zwischengespeichert wird oder in andere
regionen in denen er gerade benötigt
wird weitergeleitet wird
doch das gilt als extrem kostenintensiv
und aufwendig und schadet dem image der
erneuerbaren energien enorm doch wenn
man nur einmal auf die kosten schaut
können erneuerbare energien punkten denn
ihr wisst alle die kosten von öl erdgas
und kohle steigen rasant schließlich
handelt es sich hier um
energieressourcen die endlich sind von
2003 bis 2017 ist der weltmarktpreis für
kohle beispielsweise um knapp 80 prozent
gestiegen von 45 euro pro tonne auf 79
euro pro tonne
der preis für rohöl
hat sich in diesem zeitraum fast
verdoppelt und dieser trend nach oben
wird anhalten dagegen sinken die kosten
für erneuerbare energien in den letzten
15 jahren um etwa die hälfte
logisch wenn man bedenkt dass erdwärme
sonne wind wasserkraft und bioenergie
dauerhaft zur verfügung stehen und nicht
irgendwann aufgebraucht sind
bis 2020 sollen die kosten für
erneuerbare energien um 40 prozent
gesenkt werden so das ziel der branche
und ein ganz wichtiger punkt sehen darf
man dabei nicht vergessen
auf gar keinen fall klar werden
erneuerbare energien auch derzeit noch
gefördert doch langfristig gesehen
steckt ein großer volkswirtschaftlicher
nutzen dahinter und zwar einen nutzen
der größer ist als die kosten für ihre
förderung denn sie schonen das klima und
vermeiden dass kosten für energieimporte
entstehen zudem senkt die einspeisung
von erneuerbaren energien den strompreis
an der börse
das öko-institut angora energiewende hat
eine spannende studie zu der frage
gemacht welche kosten bis zur
energiewende im jahr 2050 anstehen und
zwar auf der einen seite auf der basis
von erneuerbaren energien und zum
anderen auf der basis fossiler
energieträger
das fazit zitat ein stromsystem dass im
jahr 2050 nahezu vollständig auf
erneuerbaren energien beruht ist nicht
nur klimapolitisch notwendig und
technisch machbar sondern aus der system
perspektive auch kostenseitig attraktiv
den berechnungen des forschungsteams
zufolge wäre ein stromsystem auf basis
erneuerbarer energien entweder gleich
teuer oder sogar günstiger als das
system das auf fossilen energieträgern
droht 64 milliarden euro kosten für das
gesamte strom system auf basis
erneuerbarer energien
gegen etwa 67 milliarden euro für ein
fossiles stromsystem somit würde ein
solches energiewende szenario nicht nur
als waffe gegen den klimawandel wirken
sondern auch als eine art versicherung
gegen das risiko hoher brennstoff und
co2 preise und jetzt wünschen wir mal um
auf die im vergleich dazu ja so billige
kernenergie im april diesen jahres ist
das war eine studie im auftrag von
greenpeace veröffentlicht wurden mit
einem
kassenergebnis limbach kann eine rein
erneuerbare stromerzeugung bei gleicher
versorgungssicherheit günstiger sein als
derzeit geplante kernkraftwerke in
mehreren osteuropäischen eu-staaten die
kosten für eine megawattstunde
produziert durch erneuerbare energie
eher liegen demnach bei etwa 100 euro
aktuelle projekte zu atomkraftwerken
liegen dagegen bei 126 euro pro
megawattstunde dazu der vorstand von
greenpeace energy nils müller
der finanzielle vorsprung der
erneuerbaren wird noch größer wenn man
zusätzliche kosten für akw störfälle und
die noch nicht eingepreist die lagerung
von atommüll berücksichtigt ja anders
für die studie ist der plan von polen
tschechien der slowakei und ungarn neue
atomkraftwerke zu bauen
denn das ist genau der punkt wie es
aussieht werden die kosten der kernkraft
nämlich im nachhinein auf die
steuerzahler umgelegt und das wird
unglaublich teuer grob geschätzt werden
es hier in deutschland mehr als 50
milliarden euro
es gibt sogar schätzungen von mehr als
150 milliarden euro inklusive dem abriss
der atommeiler
die stromkonzerne die werden sich mit
einem relativ bescheidenen beitrag von
rund 25 milliarden euro daran beteiligen
ja das hat niemand erzählt als auf die
so billige kernkraft gesetzt wurde mit
der energiewende sinken also auch die
kosten 36 prozent des stroms wurden im
letzten jahr bereits umweltfreundlich
produziert das ist also auch für unseren
geldbeutel eine gute nachricht wenn ihr
keine videos dazu und zu allen anderen
themen verpassen wollt dann endet mich
bei whatsapp dann umgeht ihren die
kaputte abo box hier auf youtube
verpasst kein video
denn über whatsapp erfahrt ihr von mir
von jedem video und zwar vor allen
anderen
ja und das täglich garantiert einfach
hier draufklicken und am besten noch
meinen schwesterkanal klicks um social
media abonnieren
da gibt es das neueste aus der social
media welt dafür hier klicken aber nicht
die genau die glocke vergessen hier geht
es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken
neuartiges wellenkraftwerk c3
wellenenergie converter 5 mal effektiver
bis dann bleibt dran